i don't know five years
they wanted 18 years
what the [ __ ] i kind of skipped the
story so so basically the guy got
arrested because
drugs were sent to my condo under my
fighter name jackie chan
oh my so this [ __ ] dude
so i arrived to the condo and they were
asking me questions like did you order a
package i'm like no did you order a
package under jackie chan i'm like no
they're like
are you in five four three let me see if
that's working yup that's working that's
working two
one what's up everybody welcome to
another episode of the genius brain
podcast we have a long time coming guest
not really because i just asked him
yesterday
but we have jeff chen from mma shredded
here
[ __ ] crazy he beat my ass yesterday
it was one of the worst experiences of
my life now it was actually really fun
um we were training yesterday and uh
it's weird because like when i watch
your videos and then i see you move you
kind of spar people based on their skill
level which is very nice
and i appreciated look i have no bruises
on my face it's great
how you doing jeff i'm doing very well
thank you for finally having me um i've
actually i've been a huge fan of david
for a very very long time i should be
talking to you or talking to the camera
i've been a huge fan obviously i already
told you that when i first met you i'm
only in la for two days and
made sure it was priority to come
come see what's it's so [ __ ] funny
like i think when we have it's always
weird meeting somebody that i've watched
online right because i've seen your
videos since like you first started
because i've always enjoyed watching mma
and learning things even though i
couldn't do any of it
you know i couldn't do any of it but i'm
like just in case you're actually really
good for only a year's training you guys
will be able to i mean i'm sure everyone
will be able to watch our sparring video
i'll be posting it soon if you funny
thing it's like i'm so critical of
myself it's like how come i don't look
like a ufc fighter dude
i always get super upset but the
interesting thing is like
like for me you know it was like a year
of just hardcore training and after a
while i was just we just started you
know training lightly here and there and
then pandemic happens so it was like
year of just trying to study this really
hard a year just fun and then two years
hiatus you know yeah i'm i'm very lucky
that my gym never closed down
of course so
yeah man um i mean your journey
especially as like a as a fighter has
been interesting to watch right just
because you were the guy that was
teaching everybody everything and then
you also fought did you find uh lfa
i did not what were you fighting before
um i fought for a rec mma i fought for
this small organization called
belleville mma
uh oh and btc yes yes yes and it was
interesting because
it's it's always fun for me to watch
somebody teach their stuff and then see
it in action right because sometimes
when you see people do pad work
you know a lot of it's like flow work
you're not going to see somebody
unloading a 13-hit combo on somebody
right but then for your stuff it was
very i think i enjoyed it because it was
applicable because you would show the
the the modality and then you would show
it in sparring and you would show its
successes and how it would fail and i
think for for people who don't know
fighting it's it's kind of nice to see
because i think when you just show that
one piece it makes you feel as if you
could just do it off the jump but it
doesn't work that way you know also it
shows that you gotta fail a thousand
times before you can do it successfully
yeah yeah and
there's something that i was telling you
yesterday when we're training is that
there's three types of guys you gotta
train with someone better than you
obviously to challenge you and that
that's that that's not all the time but
someone better than you uh someone at
your level to keep the instincts sharp
and to maintain that sharpness and then
someone worse than you so that you can
build that confident when you're
learning new techniques so i'll aspire
with good guys
better than me to challenge myself
someone that are my level when i'm in
fight camp and then people worse than me
actually when i'm trying a new technique
so say i learned a new head moving
technique i'm not gonna try it on
someone better than me i'm gonna get my
head knocked out i gotta try on someone
who's worse than me
then slowly build it up against someone
my level and then someone better and so
on that's so funny what if like the
person is hearing this like wait was i
the person that was worse than you
the guy's like yo [ __ ] this guy
i i will i you know sometimes i will
also try it on better guys and usually
that's like at the failed attempts yeah
yeah yeah yeah i mean those things are
interesting because it's like
and we were talking about this before
too where you know
when i first started doing this stuff
like i remember
there's it's it's hard to kind of um be
conscious of the transition from where
you become a flinchy person to the
person where you're a little more
comfortable because when somebody asks
they go oh how did you stop flinching i
was like i don't know
you know i don't know i think eventually
you just
accept your faith i think it's uh they
call it a blink eye and
as more punches are thrown at you it
kind of goes away it's also from a lot
of drilling like a lot of people don't
do enough technical drilling and they go
straight to sparring like you always get
guys who come to the gym first class hey
i want i want to spar i kind of do that
too because i i jump i jim hop and i i
want to do the sparring to film content
but say you're brand new never trained
before you get guys coming into the gym
hey i don't want to do technique i want
to spar
that that's a problem i'm the opposite i
i love drilling sparring is kind of like
hello we'll see well you know what again
i'm not kissing ass but that's why
you're so good when i saw you on the
puzzle like man you're very good for a
year
um and and additional to that you um you
can actually spar like i was expecting
okay this guy can hit pads let's see how
he moves but you actually move very well
that's fine i appreciate it dude it's
like
my my goal too is was always just to be
like if i walk into a gym i can at least
give somebody type of work i just don't
i don't know if it's like a korean thing
where it's like i know [ __ ] you know
because i've seen that too where i've
seen people look so good on pads i'm
talking like technically brilliant yep
and then you see them spar and they're
you know they flinch they flinch what's
the point of this so you train for
self-defense and just to protect
yourself and to be your best version and
and
that that's a great mindset and it's
similar to what i have too uh just
because i have competitor or i do this
for a living
i don't think of myself as the best i
don't believe i'm even capable of being
the best there's always people who are
better than you
with uh better
genetics
just naturally gifted or they have
better resources or they start earlier
or they're just younger um so with that
said you you shouldn't be competing
against other people you should be
competing against yourself and you
should be trying to
get to a point where you can defend
yourself against the average person and
that should be enough yeah right and it
should be just it should be for fun
i think that's the part that's really
cool it's just you know just that one
little tidbit that you said um and
something i like to always reiterate is
that competition with yourself is way
more important than competing with
others because that's endless you know
when you compete with yourself it's just
about getting better a little bit by a
little bit you know and nothing ever
comes overnight and you know a lot of us
like we see this success story at the
end but we never get to see the journey
that takes that that it takes right so
that's why even for me
like if somebody asked me hey can you
teach me how to jab i feel like i don't
think i can you know because i don't
remember you know i just remember being
bad at it and then one day it made sense
yes and i think that's the difference
between you know some people who are
fighters and some people who are really
good coaches it's like being able to
technically break down why you're either
[ __ ] up or doing it right is the hard
part because like you know i had people
come in and like oh i want to learn how
to jab i'm like you asking the wrong
person bro like i wouldn't know how to
teach you yeah like i know how somebody
taught me but when you mess up i don't
know mechanically how to fix your [ __ ]
cause one day it just clicked for me and
i don't understand the process it yeah
it takes takes a while and one of the
most common questions i get asked is
um
i got a really bad spine session i got
my ass kicked
how do i
how do i deal with that and i'm like bro
i get my ass kicked every day i just got
my ass kicked yesterday my ron's goals
day like
i love that [ __ ] feed off of me
um
i mean i wish i had the cardio to give
him a harder round but he teed off me uh
as embarrassing as you'll you'll you'll
see the content
but yeah if you guys don't know who ron
is so you know if you guys see me on
like barbell stuff or bar stuff ron was
a bart's uh muay thai coach and ron is
such a
awkward style southpaw and he's just an
aggressive dude right and you'll you
would never notice from how ron is as a
human being i've been warned by
david um who else warned that another
guy at the gym pro fighter warned me
like hey man ron he goes he goes hard
i'm like no you're kidding me i thought
he was just trolling and intimidating me
he's like no man he goes hard he gave me
a concussion and i'm like no
he's like believe me bro talk about
carry um
and it's funny because
so when i went into the gym i was
speaking to the coach and the coach was
telling me like yeah these guys go hard
like can you tell me your honest
assessment of your skill level and i'm
like i think i'm okay so i was very
intimidated he's like i'm just looking
out for your health we got a we got a
guy here who's like number one contender
number five contender i'm like
i'm gonna do my best you know i don't
want to be like hey i'm a pro fighter um
so with that said i he put me with two
ufc fighters um and right from the
beginning i
i did well and i was like okay you know
i can't handle myself and prior to
sparring ron was telling me like
these guys go these guys go hard um but
you know i can go i can go light with
you oh
whatever version of light is so so the
first three rounds i go with the ufc
bantamweight louis
and then two rounds with alex perez
so the sixth round so this is like the
the 30 minute mark now uh i'm like okay
last round this is the last round so we
did six rounds in total last round i'll
go with ron take it easy
touch gloves [ __ ] peed off of me
oh my god we're going to lane
that's ron's light dude he's like how'd
you like my life and you just wouldn't
expect it because he's such a nice guy
all smiles
yeah and he just like you know we were
talking about it earlier he has this
weird like faint stutter step too that
his rhythm is weird so it's like he
doesn't really have this um i feel like
when you see a lot of fighters they feel
you out you see them just you know
they'll bounce step they'll move around
and runs
yeah he's like a [ __ ] redwood he's
planted and he's just right and he gets
in your face
he gets in your face and just
throws yeah and he has no fear of like i
remember just back in the day just
throwing a jab at his feet he has no
fear of the jab he'll eat one and give
you seventeen so he's
he's a real fighter yeah
you know what i was talking about
earlier is like your your journey to
become a fighter i'm not sure if you
ever talked about on your stuff but
kind of like how you got into fighting
because you were talking to me earlier
like you know fighting's not even your
everything right like you you know i
think it's really weird for sometimes
you know people in my position to hear
it's like oh when i fight you know i'm
scared i'm like you [ __ ] mean man i'm
scared as hell too
and you know what's funny i talk to a
lot of pro fighters now who do it for a
living that like for me again i'm not a
fighter i'm a martial artist who had the
opportunity to fight and i fight when
there's an opportunity there are guys
who fight that's all they want to do
they fight and i ask them hey do you
like fighting they're like [ __ ] no
and i'm like okay so it's not just it's
not just like it's not just me you know
like i love the training i love sparring
i love heart sparring too
uh not yesterday but i love the heart
sparring but i don't like fighting and
the nerves that come from fighting and
the cutting weight and
sucks yeah i mean
like it's just
even just doing regular performances is
nerve-wracking but doing that with
lights with people screaming at you to
kill somebody yeah is some gladiator
[ __ ] you know yeah for sure have you has
the nerves ever gotten better
um i find i think there's two types of
people
one person one type they
the nerves get them
too much energy and they kind of gas out
for me i get tired the nerves zaps my
energy
i've had 25 to 30 fights in total like
pros and amateurs
every fight i'm telling you i gassed out
and not not gaston i was tired in the
first round
as i touched the glove
that's [ __ ] hilarious and it's like
you know when you warm up for a fight
hey man i'm done
well that's the thing when you warm up
for a fight
i'm sleepy i'm lazy i don't want to
fight anymore i'm i'm super excited up
until i get into the change rooms and
then i'm like okay
and then yeah and it just happens and
and then i'm tired and i get sleepy
and then i'm forced to do a warm-up and
then when i'm doing the world i'm like i
don't have energy and then i get in the
fight and and basically instincts take
over but but i'm tired i'm fighting yeah
tired it's like i'm fighting in the
fifth round already and and that's why i
don't like fighting i perform well
decent you know but that's why i don't
like fighting but sparring is a whole
nother game it's so fun i have my energy
i have my cardio that i actually train
for whereas i train for
for a fight my cardio is good i can do
five rounds five minutes easy i get to
fight first round i'm tired that's crazy
it's is it the anxiety or what was it
just it's just nerves it's just nerves
and and fighters actually see therapy
for it apparently i've never really
given it a shot but
so where they could just mentally kind
of tune that part out and feel as good
as they do in the spine room apparently
that's crazy because like
you because i would never know that
because i watched your your fight at 1
fc and you did well you [ __ ] beat
that tired though i was tired which is
nuts
it's funny because if you watch my not
my interview but just when they put my
hand up
uh i had some people come and be like
bro you look [ __ ] tired
you're really really heavy i'm like i
was like i was so nervous yeah that
wasn't in front of a huge crowd either
huh it was a no crowd oh my god yeah so
it actually acted as my advantage
yeah because i'm used to filming my
sparring yeah i'm all my sparring but
there weren't anybody around which is
which is great do you feel that a lot of
champions
like they're very good at tuning that
stuff out
because you don't think so well there's
two types of people right like i said
there's people like me who don't like
fighting but love training again i'm a
martial artist not a fighter and there
are guys who love fighting they eat they
breathe fighting
they take fights on short notice and
they just want to fight they don't care
if they lose they just want to fight and
they love being in there
that's not you no that's not me and
there's there's there's martial artists
who are very technical um and fight and
there's guys who are not so technical
but they have that grit and they win and
they're successful it's kind of like
like hamzad right he he looks like he
can't wait to be in that [ __ ] page
and when he talks i'm just like are you
a [ __ ] super villain he's also
technically good as well but there are
fighters i'm not gonna name names but
there's fighters out there in the ufc
who are
not very technically good but they can
take shots and they'll land one big shot
okay yeah well that was somebody like
mike perry like mike perry was somebody
who was a he's a brawler you know and
he's physically very [ __ ] strong like
i saw a video of him uh deadlifting and
he was pulling like four plates on each
side with the worst form ever i'm
talking about it looked like his back
was gonna snap and he lifted it and like
it was perfectly fine and he's one of
those guys too that when i looked at it
i'm like you're gonna have to kill this
guy in this cage or you just have to be
a lot more technically sound and that
[ __ ] with you mentally because if you
know that that guy will just keep like
ron's goals that like i mean we were
sparring so it's different i'm not
trying to go hard i wasn't going high at
all but i i knew that he
was feeling fresh and he had cardio for
days or felt like he was
and he just kept walking me down and
then because me mentally i know i'm
super tired and he's just in my face in
my face
what did i say never to do
shell up i was telling him yesterday
never shell up um because i was tired i
knew i was tired i knew he was fresh i
shelled up he just teed off of me and
then and then
he beat me mentally in that round my
lovely genius farts let's keep this
podcast sponsored and my lights on so i
ain't out in these streets selling ass
this podcast is brought to you by
ipvanish did you know that browsing
online using incognito mode doesn't do
[ __ ] that's right without added security
you might as well just give away all
your private parts that is not the line
it's private data to hackers advertisers
your isp and other prying eyes that's
why i use ipvanishvpn to make it easy to
stay truly private if you are browsing
the internet without using a vpn you are
an idiot use ipvanish it's the best you
don't have to sacrifice on speed on your
computers tablets or phones you just get
to use it and it's super dope it keeps
your data encrypted and that's super
important today with a bunch of hackers
online i kid you not if you're online
and you're not using a vpn like ipvanish
you are trippin ipvanish is offering an
incredible 70 off their yearly plan for
our listeners with a 30-day money-back
guarantee so you have nothing to lose
that's like [ __ ] nine months for free
so go to ipvanish.com brain and use
promotional code brain and claim your 70
savings that's i p v a n i s h dot com
slash brain
do you do you feel that fighting too is
is is how important is that mental part
it's very important yeah it's very very
important confidence is everything you
have to believe you can beat the guy
yeah because i was you know
it was this interview with uh tyson fury
and a bunch of heavyweights i think even
lennox lewis was there and they were
just talking he goes
in order for you to be a champion i have
to believe that every i i have i am the
best that has ever been before and
that's going to come after me right so
everybody here in this i i believe that
i could beat everybody here at this
table and whether it's true or not but
that's like the belief that you have to
see that's another problem that i have
when it comes to fighting i don't
believe that
i think there's there's so many people
better than me and i think anything can
happen to fight on the other hand
i believe i'm a true martial artist i
will spar anybody and i love to make
good content i love to get in the zone
and get those good exchanges and even if
i'm getting hit if you watch my content
i'll never
put content of just me winning it's
always a fair exchange and if i'm
dominating too much i won't post it
unless it's a tutorial because i'm
trying to teach something
um but but yeah that's why i do well
with my sparring because i'm confident
and and i know that i'm not going to get
noctual depends on sparring with yeah
yeah but for the most part you know it's
a safe environment and i can i get to be
calm and be my best and in the fight
there's people watching reputations on
the line um there's just a lot of stuff
that's going through your head that you
really have to think about because even
you know something like you know
performing stand-up if i'm doing it
at a show where it's a bunch of people
that are coming to see me i'm a lot more
relaxed versus if i'm at a comedy club
nobody knows me the pressure's on yes
cause these people don't know who the
[ __ ] i am they don't know if i'm funny
or not if i'm if i'm
gonna be a bust so there's definitely a
lot of added pressure like there's
like years ago i performed at the ice
house pasadena a lot of people don't
know this but and that set was [ __ ]
terrible by the way i didn't prep [ __ ]
and they hit me up the day before i was
like oh if they'll give me a 15 minute
spot i'll do it i went up there didn't
prepare [ __ ] but at that point i hadn't
performed at a
uh at a comedy club in like a year
and then immediately when i went on
stage my stomach started cramping up i
was like dog this should never happen to
me i've been doing this since i was 16.
you know and i felt the butterflies and
everything and literally throughout the
whole set i'm rubbing my stomach
i'm just rubbing my belly and people
don't know they're just laughing but
they don't know so i'm about to throw up
they're like oh this guy's funny
no i'm gonna yeah i'm the whole time i'm
doing my scent and i'm running rubbing
my [ __ ] belly like buddha and so but
people are giggling and i'm like they're
like oh this guy's just weird he's
rubbing his belly i'm like it's because
i'm on the verge of throwing up right
now and none of you [ __ ] up
uh afterwards i had to take a breather
and then just right when i got off stage
the cramp went away and i never felt
that before and it was because i was so
[ __ ] nervous because i hadn't done
stand-up in a while and it was like oh
and it was in the new city was in la so
i was used to performing on the bay area
uh in sacramento and i even one time
went over to the east coast to perform
and even that was [ __ ] nerve-wracking
and this time i didn't have any alcohol
i didn't drink anything cause i was like
[ __ ] i don't need you you were
telling me a funny story though when
you're
high as [ __ ] yeah you know
hey let me tell you something i need to
be on the influence sometimes to do some
real [ __ ] you know yesterday we were
talking about
like i said like you going into fighting
and stuff and you said you used to be uh
you were you uh training to be law
enforcement or were you law enforcement
so
so it'll make a lot of sense once i
explain my story but i joined when i was
15 um a buddy of mine named andrew
brought me in to train muay thai and i
just kind of fell in love with that as a
sport as a hobby my coaches at the time
was like hey man you should go fight you
know you're natural they would call me
junior masato i had like the dyed hair
when i was younger um so i just competed
as an amateur and i just took one fight
after the other and i racked up a lot of
experience in amateur and striking
zero experience in jujitsu and at the
time and then uh my coach was like you
should fight pro mma these mma guys
can't strike
i'm like
if you say so yes so he was right first
fight tko went well second fight
um
i fought a wrestler and then i had only
started working my wrestling in jiu
jitsu i was still a white belt
unfortunately um after the second round
he took me down choked me out i'm like
maybe i should stick to muay thai or
maybe i should just train some jiu jitsu
um
with that said back to the topic my main
goal at that time was uh it's against
law enforcement i spent 10 years of my
life volunteering countless hours
went to college for police foundations
university for criminology
i did everything you can to get into
policing it's very hard you need a stack
resume so i thought like i'm not
too smart up here
but i'm i think i'm gifted physically
i'm i'm explosive and whatnot and i got
that combat skill so i thought hey you
know if you're going to get into
policing you should have the combat
skills because there's a bunch of
badass police officers right now
for sure yeah um
so
i decided hey if i train jiu jitsu i get
um like a purple belt i only get a brown
boat black belt eventually and train
muay thai i would add to the resume if i
fought amateur that would add to the
resume i got life experience so not a
lot of cops can say they've been in many
i mean they they do but like
specifically like physical yeah
i thought the experience was good at
least and then when i when i got offered
to fight pros like hey i could add that
to my resume
so i had a stacked resume going into it
um but with that said i still didn't get
in until
like
10 years later but anyways um
i spent 10 years trying to get into
policing and
because i had such a hard time getting
in i would fight on the side
then i couldn't get in and then i'd
fight on the side again
then i back and forth and eventually i'm
like look ottawa which is
the capital city of canada very boring
government city only one police service
or three but um
very hard to get in so i moved to
toronto bigger city tons of police
services and to get more experience i
applied for like brinks i did like the
armored transportation i did like
hospital security i did all sorts or all
sorts of security work
and um so so it's funny because i've
been asked this question many times
which is
what made you transition from law
enforcement into uh
doing youtube
and i've always told these interviewers
it's it's a long story it's a crazy
story and i never shared with them i
just told them my life turned upside
down and i kept it at that just because
there wasn't enough time
since
so i wasn't comfortable sharing with it
so if you guys are watching it's not
that i don't want to share with you it's
just that there wasn't enough time and i
wasn't comfortable yeah everybody
everybody has their own pace when they
want to tell a certain story like time
is usually the biggest indicator for me
like even when i tell personal stories
that you know on like so for i mean like
i'm different now like i literally told
a story about how i was in a bathroom in
la and this lady approached me because i
actually walked into the women's
bathroom
and then it's like
when i walked in
this lady was like you need to get out
of here and i had headphones on so i
didn't know what was going on
and i took it out and i was like what
what you know she was like you're in the
women's bathroom and this asian lady
walks up and she goes did you ask for
his or her pronouns
that she was defending me
that though that that's that's a funny
story
my mind's a little bit more serious i'll
continue with it
so
i was in toronto working um brinks
or security hospital i can't remember my
father passed away so i got his
inheritance money to buy a condo in
toronto
then about three months later
i got a job in waterloo as a special
constable
um essentially like a university police
oh okay like i was i wasn't like an
actual cop but i started a peace officer
status
um
now waterloo is a university town it's a
dead town
but that was the only place that would
hire me so of course i'll take it now i
didn't want to
live there full time i want to just work
there and still have my condo in toronto
but i didn't want to have to just
sell the condo so i want to rent it out
and then rent rent a place out in
waterloo
and at that time i happen to have a
acquaintance
friend now he's a former friend
enemy actually
who
i rented the place to
and
the deal was i'd rent it dirt cheap for
him but he can and he can also keep the
room
just when i come back on weekends i can
crash on the the couch
my condo he can stay in the bedroom i
stay on the couch cheap rent
just on the weekends whenever i want to
party in in toronto and then i go back
to waterloo for work and i do that back
and forth
within two months of work and again i
spent 10 years of my life getting into
law enforcement i finally get in two
months i lost my job
oh [ __ ] so what happened was
one night i
uh went back to toronto to party
everyone was meeting at my place i
arrived to my condo
i believe there were seven rcmp officers
and border police officers
in my condo and outside the hallway
wouldn't let me in
and told me that the guy that was inside
is arrested is in jail
and
uh you can't go in right now i'm like oh
but this is my condo and then he's like
can we interview for for questions like
investigation and
me being naive and
not knowing what's going on and me being
a police officer myself was like yeah of
course so i told him everything i knew
which wasn't much was just
everything i knew yes i'm ready
and that's about it so they interviewed
me and then that was it and then
um yeah a week later or maybe a few days
later i guess they called
my service and they told them what
happened and they decided to
suspend me for the time being under
investigation
and then i was like oh [ __ ] like this is
scary
not that scary yet a month later
they uh arrested me
what
right
they arrested me i got put into the
toronto
toronto self detention center i was
in
like the detention center for like two
and a half weeks
it took me two and a half weeks to get
bailed out
once i got bailed out i was on under
house rest for two and a half years
two and a half years what the [ __ ] right
can you picture me in jail
i mean i can feel you you piece people
up but actually actually people were
really nice in jail oh really yeah and
it was funny because like there's
nothing to do there
um
except like a few weights or like a chin
up bar and i was like shadow boxing and
like i had like a team shadow box
hey you guys want to train
anyways that was the funniest funny
parts but but
this story gets really sad and scary so
yes i took two and a half weeks to get
bailed out
then i was uh under house arrest for two
and a half years i could not leave the
house without my mother or sister
actually even before that
the first the rules were you can't leave
the house you can't use the internet and
you can't touch a cell phone
so this went on for about a year
and i was depressed
yeah i i want to kill myself like
oh
first
how much years do you or do you think
they wanted to give
me i don't know why the the drugs was
fentanyl
[ __ ]
i don't know five years
they wanted 18 years
what the [ __ ] i kind of skipped the
story so so basically the guy got
arrested because
drugs were sent to my condo under my
fighter name jackie chan
oh my so this [ __ ] dude
so i arrived to the condo and they were
asking me questions like did you order a
package i'm like no did you order a
package under jackie chan i'm like no
they're like
are you jackie chan i'm like i don't
want to answer that but yes because
that's my fighter name but my name's
jeff chan yeah um so so that's what i
mean by like i shouldn't have said
anything because it made the case worse
by talking
and they used it against me
but uh essentially
someone that guy
my roommate
he
i guess shipped drugs fentanyl to my
condo under my name and he went to go
pick it up that day and he he got [ __ ]
for
but i guess they want to catch more
people
and want to arrest me
or he kind of tried to snitch put it on
on me yeah so anyways with that said the
drugs were shipped from overseas
so
that's why they're like okay you can't
touch a cell phone and you can't touch
the internet
so for the whole year
i was depressed i told this is very sad
but i told my mom and my sister i'm like
if i go to jail for 18 years for
something i did not do i'm gonna kill
myself like yeah i mean to be honest
with you like not even as a joke that's
the exact same thought i would think
yeah
um
yeah it was
a very very scary time wait two and a
half let me tell you like so so it was
just a year first yeah it was a year and
then after year i was going crazy my my
beard was like i was depressed all i did
was watch tv show watch i watch prison
break
over and over again by the way it's a
great show anyways um
then eventually i'm like
i asked my lawyer i'm like hey can you
like reduce the conditions for me like
i'm going crazy here
and they said that the police would
check on me every week they never
checked on me for the whole two and a
half years oh my god and alex i'll
explain later
all my thoughts on that but anyways
um
so i asked them to change the conditions
they change it so that i can leave the
house only if i'm with my assurities my
mother or my sister
and
because i was going crazy without
training uh my mom my poor mom would
drive me to the gym wait outside
technically she wasn't even allowed she
had to be inside but she waited outside
for me to train
and then after training i'd come back
home
and then
i didn't know what to do because
i knew that
if i was proven innocent i still
wouldn't be able to get back into law
enforcement just the fact that i was
associated with this this situation i
would never be able to get back in this
podcast is sponsored by purple my
friends if you know me you know how much
i love my purple mattress whenever i
travel i dream about my mattress and
coming back home to it so it could just
caress my back there is nothing i've
ever slept on in my life that's better
than a purple mattress i don't care what
you say purple is freaking amazing and
that's because only purple mattresses
have the gel flex grid i can move around
as much as i want on my side and it
stays super comfortable and there's no
like vibration going on to my lady's
side i masturbate furiously every night
and my lady doesn't wake up at all she's
like i i didn't know you were
masturbating you know why because of
that gel frex flufffrx gel flex grid my
friends i'm not playing it supports me
like my wife does on my shoulders necks
and hips no matter how you sleep my
friends purple has your back i love it i
miss it every night i travel
do not play with me i love purple
getting a great night's sleep starts
with having a great mattress get a
purple mattress go to
purple.com slash brain 10 and use code
brain 10 for a limited time you can get
10 off any order of 200 or more that's
purple.com brain 10 cone braid 10 for 10
off any order of 200 or more purple.com
brain 10 promo code brain 10 term supply
[Music]
so
you i had started the youtube channel at
the time i only like half hearted like
very half effort into it i had like
5k subscribers
um so
i knew that i wouldn't get into law
enforcement and i'm not good at anything
else so
i put all my time into youtube and
that's where it grew substantially so
you started the channel while this was
happening it blew up while this was
happening
what the [ __ ] yeah it blew up while this
was happening
so it's crazy so so
you know looking back it's it's a
blessing in disguise
and i believe things happen for a reason
and like it started to make me think
about like spiritual things and like god
do you believe in god and stuff like
i'll get into that later but
back to what i was saying um i actually
met my fiance
while i was under house arrest oh wow
she actually
stuck around and
helped me grow the business to where it
is now so if this didn't happen to me i
would have put all my focus into law
enforcement and i would have just
continued doing tutorials
in my condo gym
with like a bench press right beside me
you know i mean if you look at my
actually i privated them because they're
so bad but my old tutorials i would like
to teach jiu jitsu on the condo gym and
there'd be like a bench press beside me
yeah a curl bar or whatever yeah um
yeah funny story because when i started
going to the gym
my old coaches so i had to go back to
ottawa so i moved to toronto i'd go back
to ottawa and then my old coaches they
hooked me up they let me work so i would
teach like once a week
and uh
my fiance was a student
you're not supposed to date students but
you know we just you gotta get it when
you can you know what we we we clicked
um
and she'll never admit this but like
she'd be like hey um you're watching ufc
uh tonight i'm like yeah i'm watching
with my friends
obviously i was just going to be at home
but yeah i was watching with my friends
i didn't want to give her a reason and
she's like oh okay
and you know and then like weeks went on
our teacher and we got along and i'm
like eventually i'm like i'm just gonna
ask her out
so i asked road and
we went on our first date and my sister
followed a few meters behind the whole
the whole date
so my sister's yeah
yeah she's got my back
um and then during dinner
i'm like
i just told her straight up what
happened i'm like i'm actually under
house arrest right now my sister's
actually like a few meters around here
watching
and uh
she's stuck around she's just outside
right now damn that's a [ __ ] down ass
[ __ ] dude she's just like you know what
i don't give a [ __ ] dude
yeah so
it's funny because i'll ask her now if
you ask her right now um
i asked her like why why did you stick
around and like why i'm on under house
arrest for for fentanyl i like bad boys
don't think she meant it this way but
the way i received it was
when she spoke to me during the whole
date
there's no way
that you can be some sort of drug lord
the way you speak your personality she's
basically saying i'm like
that'll be so funny she goes listen you
are an idiot
she's like
somebody as dumb as you and you're
sitting there like what the [ __ ]
she said that in a nice way but that's
pretty much what i got and and i agree
like i i don't know drug terms i don't i
don't have that swagger like you have
much more slang than i do like i'm very
proper in the wasteland oh i'd be the
worst drug dealer ever dude i'm sorry
i'm so loud it's like you want drugs
like hey bro shut the [ __ ] up
yeah so yeah so that's what happened um
where do i start from here i got so much
to fill in
um
she stuck around with me until trial
and er
trial they asked for
three weeks and i had 18 family members
book off work
to come do this trial for me so we
rented like a mansion
to for all 18 members to stay and
support me the trial lasted
two and a half days
that was so
pretty much i say that because
they thought it would last three weeks
it lasted two days because they had zero
evidence on me the only evidence they
had on me was the fact that the drugs
was sent to my condo under my name but
the thing is too like if they convicted
you for that that would have been
[ __ ] trash because you know
i knew some very precarious people
that's a very common thing you get you
order a package under a different name
and then you bring it to your place it
happens all the time it's very very
[ __ ] common
i didn't do it
i'm not saying i did it but that's just
the typical thing that somebody would do
especially if you're getting like not
even just overseas overseas drugs
because at the time we was illegal
people would just drop off packages in
different names all the [ __ ] time
yeah and that's the thing that's so
scary is that there's so many
documentaries on
people who go to jail for things that
they did not do oh dude i would like you
said i would just kill myself i
literally years yeah i literally
believed that i was going to jail even
though
i knew i was innocent
um
i'm a big
okay sorry since that happened i'm a
huge believer and you know chinese
people have this uh
this uh this thing where it's like if
you speak too soon they believe they'll
go away
so basically what happened was
prior to all this happening i kid you
not like two months before i was like
right when i got the job actually i was
sitting i was back in ottawa sitting
down with my mom and my sister
and i'm like guys i'm just in the
happiest place of my life and i'm like
you know with your sibling you kind of
brag a bit i'm like look i just turned
25 i just got my purple belt last month
i just bought my first condo
obviously with dad's inheritance money
i just got my first mercedes which i
bought off my sister's husband's father
he sold to me for very cheap
and then i just finally got my job as a
police officer i'm gonna flash that
badge in the club
right after that everything was taken
away from me one by one wow
and so
i was led to believe that
if i say anything positive about me it's
gonna go away and
[ __ ] can just turn upside down and even
though i'm like i'm innocent they have
no evidence on me
actually be fine
i'm like i'm gonna go to jail
i was so scared
that's the crazy thing too because i've
you know there's a lot of
you know court cases right now that
people are trying to overturn of people
who are wrongfully put in put in jail
and there was um a case where there was
a kid who was in football he was
supposed to go to the nfl i believe like
he had a contract ready and this girl
um
basically testified that he he raped her
or like sexually something really bad
but then he was in jail for daniel like
ten years
and then ten maybe even more i mean he's
like he's gonna couldn't get bail right
yeah so if you you guys could look it up
i'm i'm just gonna throw out random
numbers just for story sake but it was
like 10 15 years or whatever and then
finally somebody recorded her saying
that she lied about it and then he got
out of jail but he already he was
supposed to go to the [ __ ] nfl
10 15 years he's like just gone
gone like that with that said i forgot
to mention it took two and a half weeks
to bail me out normally it would have
taken two three days
luck i don't know what it was but
i was stuck there for so long and the
the judge did not want to bail me out
he did not want to bail me out and there
was there was a 50 50 chance in my
opinion that i was gonna be stuck in
jail and that would have been two and a
half years before trial are drug
offenses taken a lot more seriously than
here in the states
yes and and at the time fentanyl was
blowing up it was all in the media so
right so so
actually i remember what i wanted to say
example out of you yes so basically the
my lawyer was like
oh sorry i asked my lord i'm like how
could they
turn my life upside down
based off that's that that evidence
and he's like i think they're they're
they just can't drop it because of the
severity of the case and then uh he
actually said the prosecutor after the
trial told him hey man i couldn't drop
the case because we're trying to fight
to just [ __ ] close it and the
prosecutor actually told my lawyer
the media man
the opera upper guys they wouldn't let
me drop it
and wow what's funny is
that the prosecutor by the end of the
trial
was a third prosecutor meaning there was
one guy left
girls left [ __ ]
sec second person
left
third person went through all the way so
i assumed they they couldn't do it
there's not enough evidence switched
another person couldn't do it switch
another person this person's like okay
i'm just gonna do it
so that's right that's why the trial
lasted for only two three days and
and yeah because there's nothing there
there's nothing there and they were
pressing for it really hard and it makes
sense that no police officer ever came
to check up on me
um they're like why i mean that's just
my assumption but i'm pretty sure
they're like
this guy it didn't do this like why
what's the point he's losing his [ __ ]
dude i had covered i was in the hotel
for six days i cried
i legit cried and it wasn't even a
battle it was a nice hotel
i i was at the window watching people
walk and i teared up i was like i want
to be you you know i couldn't imagine
being under house arrest for that
[ __ ] long i would lose my [ __ ]
mind if i didn't have my youtube channel
in something some sort of goal i would
have i don't know do you really think
man in that kind of case too then
youtube kind of like saved your life it
did i truly believe it's a blessing in
disguise if i did not
um
if this did not happen to me i would be
in water they were now working as a
police officer and i would have hated my
life i was working 12 hour overnight
shifts
you know jesus man and it's so so scary
just that idea of i'm pretty sure when
you're going through it's like dude 10
years of my life i worked up to this
point and then boom it gets taken away
you know and
i you know like we were just talking
about this yesterday too where you know
people ask about you know kind of like
my career steps and they go what happens
if i don't know youtube disappears i
don't
i'm not sure if it's because i'm being
overly defensive and like trying to make
sure i don't have like too many
emotional ties to things but for me it's
just like it because taken away it gets
taken away and just it is what it is and
i just have to start a new chapter in my
life only because like you said like
certain things happen for a reason it's
really hard to say for me sometimes that
oh they go you know what would you
change other things that you've done
it's like it's hard to say because
everything has led up to a certain point
yes if this didn't happen then i
wouldn't be here and sometimes a lot of
the wisdom the knowledge that we get is
from these [ __ ] mistakes like who
would jeff chan be if this didn't
[ __ ] happen and [ __ ] your friend by
the way dude what the [ __ ] i'm pretty
sure he was trying to rat you out
because he's hated in ottawa everyone
believes you [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] and
you know what um
it's a life lesson
it's a huge life lesson and to be honest
i've been babied by my mom and my sister
and you know they'll they'll be like
you're so unlucky you're so unlucky you
got to be more careful
and then uh i'm like true and then my
fiancee on the other hand she calls me
out she's like
it wasn't bad luck it was your [ __ ]
fault
and she's like you
you were a police officer and you
rented the house or a condo to this guy
and don't get me wrong i didn't know he
was selling drugs but i knew he was a
shady guy i knew he he was that guy who
i'd go to clubs with and he'd get into
fights
he was a troublemaker again i didn't
know he was a drug dealer but he was not
the greatest guy
but he was a friend and he was a friend
that i grew up with
that's where we get [ __ ] up a lot
though well that's what a lot of people
get [ __ ] up with because you grew up
with these guys and
they're your friends you feel loyalty to
people sometimes when they won't do the
same for you and it's only because
there's time like we've invested time
into each other yeah and i think yeah we
were talking about these institutes this
is where we we fumble a lot because
we're we're misconstruing what makes
somebody a good person it's oh i just
known this person for a long doesn't
that doesn't mean [ __ ] [ __ ] you kind
of have to look for and i really
actually like i mean just sidetrack
rules so you know what what your fiancee
said too it's personal responsibility
it's responsibility you know like we
could say as much as we want i got the
worst [ __ ] luck but at the same time
we made personal choices that allowed
for this to happen and sometimes when
people say that like he's like oh you
shouldn't blame yourself because you
were the victim i don't like being a
victim right there are times where yes
you are a victim but when you take
control of the narrative and you say
okay i could have done certain things a
little better number one it helps you
control the chaos and helps you be a
better person right because it's easy
for you know especially in your case too
it's like well i just rendered my place
out
i don't know why this happened to me
that's
a such a defeatist mentality and you
can't escape from that you know before
we continue let's keep this podcast
sponsored you know what i'm going to
talk about i'm talking about that better
help my friend this podcast is sponsored
by betterhelp because i love betterhelp
because betterhelp helps me be a better
version of me every day people always do
not realize that physical symptoms like
headaches teeth grinding and even
digestive issues can be indicators of
stress and let's not forget about doom
scrolling sleeping too little sleeping
too much under eating and over eating my
friends this is all stuff that you can
get help for at better help listen i
love my better health therapist and
honestly this dude helps me through all
these dark times that you know sometimes
i feel listen i'm a comic but it doesn't
mean that i'm not going through [ __ ] and
honestly my better health therapist
counselor helps me out my friends i love
better help give it a try you have
absolutely nothing to lose better help
is customized online therapy that offers
video phone and even live chat sessions
with your therapist so you don't have to
see anyone on camera if you don't want
to it's much more affordable than
in-person therapy so give it a try and
see if online therapy can help lower
your stress genius brain listeners get
10 off their first month at
betterhelp.com genius that's
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p dot com slash genius
yeah if if i continued with that mindset
and i continue hanging out with those
guys
it could happen to me again yeah so you
know i appreciate my fiance she's she's
she's she's a keeper and she's she's
real she tells me
she calls me out i got a lot of stuff
it's hard though you know um a lot of
people go to this stage in their life
where
they do have to learn how to assess and
learn how to cut people out and
sometimes it's not even just for the
fact that they're quote-unquote bad
people sometimes you have to cut people
out because
i don't want to say cut people out as a
definitive way to say it but sometimes
people just grow apart right and so we
try to hold on to things that we feel a
certain loyalty to right but at the same
time like to expect certain things out
of somebody else when they won't do the
same for you it's it's it's a lose-lose
situation for me right i just kind of
progress in my life and i do what i have
to do and if you want to come along you
can right and i
talked about this on a previous podcast
too with my buddy joe it's like the idea
that sometimes we feel
what is that what is that it's like
survivor's guilt like sometimes i just
want to carry these people with me yeah
you know i was like i'm doing i gotta
i'm gonna drag you up with me
but you always end up being the person
that's drowning because you can't carry
people's dead weight they have to carry
it themselves and you guys have to grow
together for sure and you know that's
where we get [ __ ] up you know
yeah you just got to kind of go your own
path sometimes as hard as it is um
but yeah and look at your position now
like you've you've kind of developed
this channel too where
you you're helping a lot of people out
there's some people men like
i i think i really kind of fell in love
with your channel and what you did was
because i could tell how much you care
about your content it's not just hey
guys my name is jeff and i'm gonna teach
you guys how to punch like those that's
very utilitarian like i could tell that
you enjoy what you're doing oh i love it
i love you this is so sorry to cut you
off but whenever i'm on vacation
you should be going on vacation
and training is my vacation actually
making content is my vacation that's
what i love that's what i love doing so
i i even promised my fancy i'm like not
going to drop by any gyms this time
because she helps me film so it's
hassle-free
i'm not i'm not going to drop any gym
but i'm like i'm missing all these
opportunities like yesterday i got my
ass kicked but i had a great time i have
good good footage
and when i went for san francisco same
thing when i went to hawaii same thing i
got good footage and that's what i like
doing
uh
yeah i mean you're a true martial artist
you know and i think
that's what a lot of people are looking
for not just in terms of being a martial
artist but finding something that you
truly enjoy and love and like like we
were just talking about if certain
things didn't happen who would have
known what your path would have been you
might you might have just been a cop for
another like 10 years and then you had
been like i actually liked this but
within those 10 years you didn't get too
late it was too late and and that's the
thing is uh procrastination this is
different but but reminds me of another
topic which is procrastination there's
so many people have been influenced and
motivated to start their own channels um
they're like jeff
let's start a channel together or i'll
start our channel help me out like give
me some tips um and and they start it
and within a few months they don't see
the views they give up and i tell them
it takes a very very very long time long
time dude i've followed channels that
had actually
at least they started but there's a lot
of people who say it but they never
start they don't start at all
procrastination is the biggest barrier
i've i've literally followed channels
that started with like 2 000 followers
and then four years and now they have
millions i'm like it took them a long
time there's or there's a guy who has a
channel called not another cooking show
he was getting like five thousand views
six thousand seven thousand ten thousand
now he's over at like half a million
views per video but i've been following
for like three four years and it took a
while it took pandemic hit and then
people started cooking more and then the
[ __ ] popped off and i was so glad
because that guy who does the not
another cooking show i think he's one of
the better um food creators out on the
space
and i would you know i would share his
stuff to other people hopefully his
channel will blow up i mean he doesn't
even know who the [ __ ] i am but when i
watch his stuff it reminds me of your
channel it seems like oh this guy really
[ __ ] enjoys what he's doing and
that's the type of reason why like
i you know have you on this podcast
because i like interviewing people that
kind of motivate me and kind of put me
in check of like because i've had this
success for quite a long time sometimes
i forget what it's like to be hungry
right we get very complacent yes
and so i stopped wanting to be better
i'm like oh this is good you know checks
are coming in you're fine but there was
a moment in my life where there this
wasn't here and every day i worked
harder to become better and so when i
see people who are enjoying what they're
doing it kind of refreshes me it's like
oh i should get back to this too where
you just enjoy it and sometimes i over
overthink about content which i never
used to be that person i used to be like
let's just do this and throw it up and
see what happens and now i'm just like
okay what's the game plan year how many
uploads a week are you doing and that
always stunts me inside and i just don't
start sometimes well it's kind of funny
because i was surprised at how relaxed
you are you're just like hey you want to
go in the podcast tomorrow and i'm like
expecting you to be like oh so we're
gonna we're gonna do this prepare this
this this it's like i literally just
came here you wanna do a podcast okay
sat down on one two three i'm like whoa
what what
well this is like a very casual podcast
like i don't i don't like structuring
this in a way where it feels like an
interview because it's not fun that way
for sure you know i think certain people
like podcasts like that like there's a
podcast i follow dak shepard his stuff
is very armchair expert very very
organized very precise and he's a really
great interviewer um for this podcast
it's just me wanting to talk to people
that i like and so you know if we get
great stories out of we do if we don't
then whatever you know and your story to
me is very personal and super dope that
you're you're telling this because the
process is so [ __ ] important nobody
would ever know i didn't [ __ ] know
you were doing that while you had house
arrest dude
which is crazy to me it blows my i don't
know how you're doing that to stay
motivated to to upload these videos
consistently on the idea that you just
might go to jail for 20 years well
believe me it took it took a while it
took a while but uh
in my head i eventually got to the point
where i'm like
i'm innocent it's going to be fine it's
going to be fine
but now i got to think of a plan
afterwards you know um okay against law
enforcement i got to do something and
my what's the word like
what's the word for like uh relief was
training yeah so when i was during that
in that situation therapy therapy i was
watching i was watching tv watching
prison break
i'm like i can finally leave the house
with my mom i got trained i went to
train i got my mind off things because i
was training and then
i met my fiance at the you know if i say
now my mind's on a girl and that helped
so much and then
the the second year and a half it went
by much faster it was still bad still
very scary but it went much faster
because now i had my fiance with me and
she's just [ __ ] rock solid you were
talking about uh you're you're kind of
you know during this time and you know
you kind of went through a quarantine
before quarantine
you know you got to think about it like
you you so uh
you know you're talking about you're
you're wrestling with the idea of like
spirituality what were you what was
happening during that time um so
okay
uh the story is kind of hard to explain
so basically i was telling you that
i didn't think i was gonna get bailed
out
when i was in prison
and the judge made it sound like he did
not want to let me out because the
prosecutor was
was [ __ ] crushing me just like using
everything against me and it just didn't
seem like he was gonna let me out
so
there was like three days that i had to
be in court to find out if i was gonna
bail out or not and
the first two days
the guy's like why should he get bailed
out kind of thing and then my lawyer
like didn't know what to say
and
the third day
he
the judge was like on the side of not
letting me get bailed out
and then suddenly he just switched his
mind and bailed me out
now during that day
and a lot of people who are watching
this are going to say like you're just
you're full of [ __ ] but
the judge was doing this
all
all day just [ __ ] going like this
and my uncle was like that's that's
something very familiar um to my father
my father had a tumor
and my father used to do this all the
time and my uncle was just like like why
is he doing that suddenly he didn't do
it the first two days
and then um
suddenly he just bailed me out and like
holy [ __ ] like that that's amazing
sort of
anyways
my uncle literally walked up to the
judge after and was like you should you
should go see a doctor or the hospital
like there seems to be something wrong
with you like i've seen those symptoms
before and he was genuinely concerned
so
anyways i get back home and all my
family obviously come sees me the next
day but the night before when i got back
home
it was a new house i've always slept in
my bedroom
never have i not slept in the in that
bedroom that night i slept on the couch
so the next day i
uh have all my family come visit me and
are like asking me what happened and my
aunt she's
that aunt that has like that sixth sense
and she has tons of ghost stories and
she god
so basically um
she sat down and my mom's like because
because people will go to my auntie like
like
when a grandfather dies they'll be like
did you see him in her sleep and she
literally will like it's crazy like that
anyways so my mom went up to her and she
was like
you got to talk to to to harry like my
father you got to get him to help my son
and she's like he is um last night
jeff was sleeping here well i she dreamt
that jeff was sleeping on this couch
and i was sleeping on his his uh
like just lying on his head and he says
i am taking care of him
and it's crazy because i've never slept
on that couch before
and she
she dreamt that last night
your mom or my aunt so my mom spoke to
my aunt and your your aunt is the more
prophetic one with you yeah okay and my
aunt told my mom that
and i'm like
[ __ ] i slept creepy i just slept on that
bed that or that couch that night
and the night before
the whole headache thing and my dad had
a tumor and was sick for half of my life
most of my life
wow
so you're wait your dad had a had a
brain tumor yeah it was so close to his
brain that he couldn't remove it so he
had to keep that that whatever and so
that's why he constantly did this a lot
holy [ __ ] yeah so that's why
yeah it's crazy
did um
what did the lawyer say i mean that the
judge said when he would you know the
[ __ ] oh i don't know yeah
my uncle just told me that my uncle told
my mom that my mom told me that we
didn't we didn't find a way
that's [ __ ] true yeah so so you know
if you didn't hear the whole father's
side of the story and just heard the
judge doing this you'd be like what is
that yeah but like from my perspective
i'm like holy [ __ ]
what did that do for you like mentally
when you heard about that [ __ ] did it
make you i cried yeah man my dad's
watching out for me
that's crazy yeah and what how old were
you when your father passed away 25. oh
man you're young and and what's even
more sad is that like
you know my family we're not we're not
rich yeah uh by any means but they work
really hard and my dad has been had been
sick for half my life
really early on he had a business a
restaurant business and he had to close
it down because he got sick so it was my
mom who raised us
at least brought in the income yeah and
my mom is not educated my mom you know
works at hotel
and so
we weren't struggling but my mom worked
really hard my father was not working
because he was sick he was on medication
and
you know obviously me and my sister are
ambitious we want to go university want
to work whatever whatever and you know
years like two years after my father
passed away my mom told me like
you know uh your father told me that
like you know before he passed away that
he
really wanted to give you extra money to
buy a condo
which i did use that but he wanted to
get money for you somehow but he didn't
know how
and he eventually passed away
um
and and to explain that more was that he
had a tumor
his whole life or sorry half of my life
but he didn't die from the tumor
and it was a rare disease a rare disease
that my
or his doctor said occurs
one in like a hundred chance
jesus so he had a tumor that you would
think he would eventually pass away from
but if that wasn't it it was a
rare disease
and
uh this is probably just my mom saying
it but my mom was like he didn't he
didn't want to live he wasn't trying to
live so then
me just like overthinking him like my
father passed away
so that he can help me with my life yeah
you know what i mean
that's trippy what was the uh disease
that he had i don't even know what it's
called it's like a really rare disease
one out of a [ __ ] hundred yes
one percent of something
very very very small chance
jesus yeah what was it like dealing with
your dad you know especially because he
was like sick for for half of his life
what to be honest like i do have a lot
of regrets because we argued a lot
because he when he was on medication he
would act like a child yeah
he was very out of it
um
he would like
make he would eat peanuts
he'd be playing games on the computer
like chess
and uh because he had nothing to do he
had no job right yeah and he was always
very sleepy he would like eat peanuts
and make a mess everywhere and i don't
pick it up and like i used to like get
in arguments with him
i mean it's hard to be
you know for you to grow up and starting
to be the parent of your parent that
early on yes you know especially when
you're in your 20s you have no [ __ ]
patience you have no wisdom no knowledge
exactly no empathy it's so difficult you
know and some people are just forced to
grow up a lot earlier than everybody
else and it's just you there's no
warning for it you know it's just hey
your dad's sick this is how he is and i
never
it you know because my my my grandma had
um
like severe alzheimer's you know and
then you don't know how to process
what's going on and i'm like in my early
20s i just know i just see this woman
deteriorating and then you know as a kid
i don't understand what my dad's going
through because he's like super
short-tempered he's like yelling at me
but he was going through his own process
of feeling guilty because he couldn't
take care of his parents but as a 20
year old i don't know this stuff yeah
you know i just see myself as like my
dad's a [ __ ] [ __ ]
but you don't know what they're
personally going through you're young
yeah yeah like even though i knew my dad
was on medication i didn't really
understand the effects of it and it made
him drowsy and made him out of it and
that's why i was acting that way and i i
didn't really know because i mean i
guess i might have known but i i guess
less immature and yeah yeah that's
insane man your story is [ __ ] nuts it
was crazy like like your [ __ ] story's
nuts
yeah like and that that's why i tell
people like
things happen for a reason so if you're
like
at the lowest end you gotta stay strong
you know yeah i think like your biggest
thing too is like you you met somebody
in your life like your fiance that kind
of helps you
refocus everything and we were talking
about how it really is like the closest
people in your circle that really
influences you because it also you know
offer for her position for her to hear
your story and then she goes well
there's also personal responsibility on
your part it's actually not a easy thing
to do a lot of people can't say that to
somebody especially when they're close
to them because they don't want to hurt
their feelings right but
that's really good of her to be able to
you know openly communicate with you and
say hey
it's not bad luck you made poor choices
and you have to learn how to accept that
and then you know get better from it
especially because i saw that pad
hitting video and that [ __ ] made me
laugh so hard
she she she definitely
challenges me in all all ways of life
like uh
yeah she challenges me not not just this
she's she's a good one
yeah she's the one who's actually trying
to
not pressure me but she's like you
should you should expand the business
you you go to the states you know why
why settle down ottawa
where there's not much opportunities you
know you should go and you're young go
go and you know she she kind of
she's like that second
brain whatever yeah yeah i mean she's
she's somebody there that's you know
it's like a good backbone to you yeah
right and you know with her whispering
in your ear and saying like good things
like
it's it's very important to find
somebody like that
and you know
a lot of the questions that we get here
is like how do you find a great partner
it's like
there's like this
it's hard to say because i don't
i never expected to be with somebody
that kind of like filled in a lot of my
um
what's the word i'm looking for just
downfalls right like the holes in my
game right because
you know as a young guy you know you
kind of have a lot of ego you feel like
oh you're you know you're a pretty
complete person and then you meet
somebody that points out all your
[ __ ] fools oh boy tell me about it
tell me about it
like
yeah you know she's like you know
something small like i remember when we
first started dating she goes
your face is dry how come you don't use
lotion
i never knew my face was dry and the
moment she said that that's all i saw i
was like what is this like my skin's
terrible you know but she pointed it out
and i couldn't get it out of my head you
know and she's like you know you should
probably look at a mirror every time you
go outside just once and then i'm like
oh my god i have boogers everywhere you
know but i didn't know this stuff but
you know you start being with somebody
that points out the things that aren't
great things about you it's not because
they're they're mean and obviously
there's tact yes right but
it's it's good to have that person in
your life for sure even friends to just
be honest and call you out on things
because there are certain friends where
i just feel like there's a boundary and
i don't want to
i feel like if i give them
that
warning heads up whatever you want to
call it that advice he's going to take
it the wrong way and he's going to get
angry and that's not good
yeah it's best that you just straight up
tell them but there are certain people
that i i won't cross the boundary and
unfortunately they're gonna have to
learn the our way yeah you know some of
that some people just have to learn that
way and i i feel like sometimes even
when i
i don't do it often just because i do
believe the people around me now are
pretty smart they can figure it out
themselves and you know you just nudge
them in in the right direction
but also too i've also learned to give
advice to people in a way that where i'm
not
emotionally involved too much because
when you give somebody advice how i i
believe anyways like it's give it and
they can take it or leave it i don't i
used to do something when i was younger
which was a
a huge fallacy was i would give somebody
advice and i get mad at them for not
taking it well they're an individual
they could do whatever you want with it
you just do good things because you're a
good person and you feel like it was the
right thing to do whatever happens after
that you just let it go yeah and i think
before i would be like this [ __ ]
idiot you know i told this [ __ ]
a million times not to do it you just
did it anyways and we would get into
altercations
and they know i'm right but then my
approach was so stupid because it's like
that's this person's life it's not mine
it's not my responsibility you just did
it because you thought it was a good
idea if they take it it's on them if
they end up in jail then all right
yeah no i i definitely agree uh
i've been in those situations many times
as well yeah man um it's kind of like
nuts just to see your your progression
in this space too just because like i
said not a lot of people
stick around
you know especially in this content
heavy
world in society you're talking about
youtube yeah youtube man i love what i
do i'm telling you i love it like there
is a fear of me where one day youtube
crashes or whatever online crashes
um but right now if i can keep this the
way it is i love my life i could not be
any happier you know
for vacation i don't need my like so we
went to hawaii before we came here and
like everyone said oh you're you're so
lucky you're in hawaii
um
and i
i had fun i had fun i'm spending time
with family but i didn't have
i had the most fun when i went to a gym
it was like what was hawaii like dude
the gym there was something
the truth is like me and my fiance were
not much of a beach person anyways so
so yeah but we enjoyed the food a lot of
pokeballs yeah we got hawaii together
man like i'll show you around oh yeah
you'll end up being a heavyweight by the
time you got a new store coming out
right yeah yeah so we're opening up a
store uh jumbi matcha me and joe and
then um
our friend greg also joe's cousin um
we're opening one in the royal hawaiian
in waikiki so like i've been going to
hawaii two i go two three times a year
wow yeah i love i like the people you
know it's just very nice they are very
nice yeah also we're we're like the
white people in hawaii yeah
we're we're the majority
we usually go to honolulu or i always go
to um like oahu
yeah because uh just all my friends are
there okay and um how do you have so
many friends there just i just been
going so much and then you just connect
with people and you know some of these
people are allowing like friends for
life and so when i over go there it's
just like family um
and hawaii too like i think i really
enjoy just because they're an example of
people who
you know
when you look at it especially when it
comes to natives and how they were just
[ __ ] over like they still managed to
number one care about the place that
they live in like
how often do you see trash on the floor
there i mean you'll see it here and
there just from like tourists and stuff
i was gonna say maui was really
beautiful very clean
uh
honolulu we went to waikiki i believe
yeah a little bit more busy like like
tourists oh yeah that's like the vegas
so [ __ ] in hawaii there's a lot of
homeless people too i remember i gave uh
i gave three burgers to the homeless but
they were super nice homeless people
yeah like one had like a very high soft
spoken voice i was like you're such a
nice guy thank you they got they got uh
well hawaii kind of got [ __ ] over
because places like new york i think
this the state of hawaii had sued new
york because new york they were sending
their homeless people over to hawaii
because it's the weather's nice there
and they would clean them up give them a
free ticket but they would leave them
there and so you know like hawaii gets
[ __ ] over a lot of those you know
places but these are some of the most
positive people ever and you know
they're trying to get a lot of their i
want to say like actual
um
like sovereignty but just kind of like
their identity back right because you
know the the i
like natives deserve their respect right
and
there's not a lot of like native
speaking hawaiian people left either
because you know your culture gets
washed out a lot but these people
are always a reminder of you know
whether you're a native or you're a
local of really appreciating what you
have they they really have a big
emphasis on spending time with people
that you love
and um i know people in hawaii who work
like three four jobs but i never hear
them complain they they say i'm lucky to
live like i'm lucky to live in hawaii
that's something that you're saying um
when we're driving is that uh you know
your your mother
would never complain about her work and
even though you guys were struggling at
the time you you never uh complain and
that's how you get your mindset from
yeah it's it's it's important because
it's also could it could have been
because of like my christian upbringing
too it's like the idea that you always
have more than enough right and my my
level of happiness has never been based
on a bigger home and material things so
the way i derive happiness and joy is
from doing things you know for sure
traveling seeing things meeting people
having conversations that's another
thing that uh my fiance changed about me
i actually she didn't change this part
but like when i was in university i was
all about like the gucci like louis
vuitton like hung out with like
vietnamese people yeah
[ __ ] [ __ ] you man
i wish bart was here that reminds me of
uh uncle uncle sam
yeah i was really materialistic
but
now man i wear sweats every day
this is my wedding outfit dude yeah i i
literally have two pairs of uh
jogger shorts three t-shirts and the
rest is training gear one one luggage on
this whole whole like three week trip i
love don't give a [ __ ] what i wear
anymore as long as i'm comfortable
with that said i i used to um only
travel to asia
china asia or china thailand
but
once i met my fiance she kind of opened
opened my eyes she's traveled to 67
different countries get the [ __ ] out of
here that's nuts she's traveled
everywhere and she's very like
you know when we're at home you know we
save we we cook at home and stuff but
when we go out or so when we travel we
spend and uh
we fly everywhere we fly everyone she's
all about like that experience and she's
already traveled to all these countries
and now she's traveling and taking me
and wants me to experience all this and
it's really opened my mind to these two
[ __ ] need to meet she's
she lived in japan for
yeah
she lived in japan for like a year and
then also and so she could speak you
know mandarin japanese korean and
english and she's a she's a [ __ ]
wanderlust she loves [ __ ] traveling
and she's the one that opened my eyes to
traveling too
yeah these [ __ ] i told you
right right when you had a few uh
comments about your wife i'm like man
she's so similar to my wife my fiance
yeah that's not my wife we've been
engaged for a very long time but covid
hit and then now now we're just like
focusing on other things yeah but i
treat her like my wife yeah that's
that's that's
that's pretty [ __ ] nuts man like i i
really find that
it's crazy when you just meet the right
person and how they can just really fill
those holes in your game like and i'm
you know i'm not very good at being like
verbally
you know appreciating her a lot because
i never got it as a kid so to say
somebody you know
like hey you're doing great and stuff it
doesn't really come to my mind because
for me like i said before everything's
about personal satisfaction i don't need
somebody to tell me good job as long as
i feel it so
for her like i mean i should probably
tell this to her faces like she's really
like opened up my world in my life
because number one i never thought that
i would have been so strong enough to
find somebody that made me feel weak at
times right it's like oh [ __ ] like i i
do have things i need to work on and fix
and like i always tell people too
especially when it comes to
relationships you'll find out that being
with somebody is not really about
finding more finding out more about them
it's more about you find more about
yourself it's like true because they
become that mirror and you just can't
run away from it yeah you know yeah
definitely
um i'm gonna say something before
but i forgot sometimes this happens i
don't know if i spar too much but this
doesn't happen like i have something i
want to say and then uh and then it just
hey that's just like i don't even spar
and that [ __ ] happens to be all the time
they're like dude why do you have cte
it's like i don't know bro like that
yeah it's another funny thing about me
is um
my fiance
hates fighting
doesn't doesn't like the sparring i want
to say hates but doesn't like the spark
hates fighting doesn't like the sparring
and she thinks like a hidden head too
much
and she thinks i'm getting slower
but what she doesn't know is that i've
been very slow all my life like i'm just
not gifted in that way funny story
and i only
two funny stories when i was in
whatever elementary school i was doing
kumon for english of course and i'm
canadian born that's hilarious dude
that's funny another thing that i just
recently found out maybe like a year ago
was my mom she was telling my fiance at
the time but she was telling me us that
when i was in kindergarten my teacher
recommended that i go to special school
she thought i was [ __ ]
oh my god dude apparently that was hella
fun apparently i was so hyper that like
you know when we're sitting in a circle
i would like just get up and like start
running and like tapping people in the
head like apparently i was crazy i don't
know
this you know what it's just like the
level of like dealing with kids in
education back in the day was just
really behind anytime a kid acted up or
they couldn't focus it was like this kid
a little [ __ ] you know
he's like no the kid is just you know
either it could be a wide wing range of
spectrums and learning how to deal with
kids because
that's why sometimes school curriculums
are very hard because sometimes they're
very stiff and like these teachers
because i wanted to be a teacher and um
the way they would teach kids would be
just very general right and it's evolved
a lot since then a lot a lot of you know
teachers are becoming a lot more um
keen to this
but you know when a kid would just move
around because i was one of those kids
moving around oh god i just couldn't
stop moving and it was just the idea
that i was just very hyperactive yeah
and i need to get my wiggles out so you
know when i was a kid my parents put me
in taekwondo i was in soccer and that's
where i would probably i would thrive
because yeah because that's you know i
get my [ __ ] out it was just so weird
because i was so fat but i couldn't i
would move so much i was like what what
is this kid eating you know like she's
so large but he moves so much you know
which i think that's a funny thing too
is like when you know when nick and i
first started training he goes you're
pretty agile for a big
you move fast i i always play sports
well well funny thing i didn't i didn't
tell you at the time but uh you know i
was playing with a lot of head movement
i was like dipping my head forward and
like
i normally have a really good reaction
to just like pull back and cross he
caught me a few times like you'll see on
the video you caught me at good times
all right only highlight this stuff and
then delete everything
good and yes you got long arms yeah
longer than i expected longer than i
think yeah you know so it's like i i
always have to just be mindful of
you know kind of like my body and my
spatial awareness i mean kickboxing is
still very hard for me um
just the just the the added threat of
the leg it's just something i always
have to be mindful of you gotta use
those long legs your advantage too i
know i gotta use my [ __ ] legs and you
know i just the setups are a little
weird because i can't see the openings
yet with the kicks because it's you know
two years since i've it's been a while
yeah yeah so you're doing
two years under training and then
sparring with me did very good oh why
thank you dude yeah
this video i'm just gonna watch it just
cringe i'm like oh you [ __ ] idiot
says that korean side like you don't
remember no matter what i see it's just
like this [ __ ] [ __ ] sucks like you
piece of [ __ ] like i i always just want
to go back and let me redo this but i
think one of the things that i had to
learn too is like sometimes you have
good sparring days sometimes it just
[ __ ] sucks all the time and you just
have to accept it and um
i didn't really know that until
something you know when sessions would
be bad i would just beat myself up and
then i would just drill by myself over
and over and over and then sometimes
just like just relax bro like it's not
that big of a deal yeah for sure for
sure drilling is important and it's good
that you have that mindset that you do
go back and practice on your own a lot
of people don't drill enough
that's another common question i get
asked is like how do i
get my combos to come out naturally
you got to drill people just want to
spar you got to drill
yeah yeah it's just that the constant
exposure is really important
um which i didn't really think about
either you know like i said
eventually the blinking stopped
eventually i wasn't so scared to let go
of the cross right hesitant right and i
was talking to very briefly with uh nick
the year and he was saying like we were
seeing how we go through phases so like
one month we'll we'll be throwing like
these go-to combos and the next month we
start doing these and then third month
we do this and then and then
uh i see someone else do a combo that i
did three months ago i'm like i used to
do that all the time but i just stopped
doing it and it's because i happen to
drill different things and it just
changes yeah i think that's that's the
cool part of being a martial artist like
the journey of constantly growing and
learning and it's and it's [ __ ]
endless because number one the sport
continues to evolve and even if the
evolution wasn't there there's already
so many different modalities that you
could really learn from and people the
cool thing is when you start to you know
develop your own style that's where i
feel like some of the most successful
fighters are like they they're unique i
agree and and that's actually very
aligned with the way i think so
say i didn't have a channel because i
treat my channel as my martial arts
journal i vlog my training um i learn a
new move i go and try it
i get my failed attempts my successful
attempts and if i didn't
you know if i didn't capture these
combinations then i would be more
hesitant to move on with different
techniques because now oh what if i
forget those but like now it's like it's
like a journal right like i collect i
collect i collect sparring footage at
different gyms i collect techniques that
i landed in sparring i collect me
getting my ass kicked you know what i
mean so it's a journal so i think a lot
of people who you know if anyone
watching this is looking to start their
own channel or their martial arts
journal journey
or on their channel they should treat it
like a journal like people have diaries
where they they write down what happened
that day for me instead of writing down
hey today i landed the hook you could
see it
yeah
i mean that's that's that's the great
thing is it's constant growth and you
know not being afraid to look at the
[ __ ] that you just suck at that's that's
really really important and you know we
live in a world where the highlight reel
is the best real and people delete the
[ __ ] that they don't like to see it's
like dude
the part where you're [ __ ] up matters
the most it's like because if that's not
happening for you
you know
were you perfect like
it's [ __ ] impossible i can't wait to
look back at the uh
sparring footage from yesterday we're on
school singing i'm gonna get you next
time i'm kidding i'm kidding but that's
cool though like i still find it so
funny
because i was like how was rod it's the
first thing you know it's funny that's
that's the first thing bart asked me too
he just messaged me he messed with me
this morning house sparkle ron i'm like
he literally kicked my ass
to be fair i didn't have the cardio but
he did kick my ass
but
i just that's the first thing i wanted
to ask was like
you know there's always so many stories
about him you know
it's just so funny because i never
believed them i never believed them i
think this guy's always smiling he's
like that's what i mean right just like
this all the time you know
well guys uh that wraps up this episode
of the genius brain podcast hope you
guys enjoyed jeff's story you can find
him mma shredded on youtube also on
instagram if you guys want to learn from
him he has online courses and programs
that you guys can pick up
i picked it up it's pretty [ __ ] fun
very unique very different so give it a
go try it out if you've never tried a
martial arts before give it a go man i i
truly believe it's something that
everybody should try it's it's difficult
in a different way and i think it's a
very humbling type of sport you know um
you know before we end we were also
talking about it's one of the most
honest things that you can do because
you could talk a big game as much as you
want but when you're on a mat it has to
show so the honesty in the sport is what
i really enjoy and it kind of helped me
realize too like where i'm at personally
because before this i was like i got
hands i could do this [ __ ] and then you
see somebody with hands and like oh that
guy's got hands like the real hands he
has
i do not i live in this fantasy world
where i think i can throw hands because
i was just fighting other people that
couldn't fight so it's just two people
just swinging at each other
i know i know we're ending this but it's
funny because
you know i was telling you that uh when
i went to oyama yesterday the coach was
like can you give me an honest
succession of
assessment of your skill level like tell
me
i'm like i'm
i think i'm okay yeah you know it's
better than being like hey i'm a pro
fighter i'm with one championship
then then i get i get my ass kicked you
know it's better to be like hey i'm i
i'm trained i'm i'm okay i'm gonna do my
best yeah
yeah it's you know honestly it's great
well uh you guys can catch genius brains
every sunday genius brings genius brain
every sunday at 12 p.m once again go to
mma shredded check out his uh channel
and you guys probably know who the [ __ ]
he is
and we'll see you all next time peace